pour cette séquence
échec et mat alors messieurs la question
qui va vous est posée c'est la religion
est elle encore l'opium du peuple
une question vous voyez d'origine
marxiste que vous vous reconnaîtrez
alors pour répondre à cette question
jacques duquesne alors jacques duquesne
vous êtes journaliste à la croix depuis
bien longtemps hélas hélas mal à croire
mais pour la pour l'ag vous avez été le
confondateur du point et en ce qui
concerne l'express on ne parlera pas de
votre devenir je crois qu'il s'est
arrêtée a répété ce qu'on a trouvé que
je vais propager voilà alors vous éditez
un nouveau un nouvel essai dieu malgré
tout alors lequel vous poser la question
de savoir si on peut encore croire en
dieu dans cette époque où on ce massacre
malgré le mal du monde aussi parce que
les bassins qu'on peut dire ce sont les
femmes qui sont méchants mais le mal du
monde c'est à dire les ratés de la
création les éruptions les cyclones
savez-vous jacques duquesne que le débat
n'est pas encore commencé et que vous
allez je vais devoir vous interromps
face de vous michel onfray
non ce sera le travail de vous
interrompre pour son traité d'athéologie
un traité qui a fait beaucoup de bruit
ces derniers temps alors vous êtes
philosophe et depuis 2002 vous avez créé
l'université populaire de caen vous
professez une contre philosophie si on
peut dire on vous dit philosophe du
plaisir mais vous définissez comme un
marque s'offre odien et en tout cas
comme un athée sans concession l'on peut
dire quand même que votre livre même
s'ils s'appellent traité d'athéologie et
surtout une charge terrible contre les
monothéismes alors on va tout de suite
répond à la question va commencer par
vous gêne vous voulez bien la religion
est elle encore
l'opium du peuple je ne crois pas du
tout heures d'abord il faut distinguer
entre la religion et la foi et ce qui
m'a frappé dans le livre michel onfray
qui s'appelle at il alors je me dis il
va parler de dieu mais non mais il parle
des religions c'est pas la même chose
que les églises et fait des bêtises tout
au long des siècles que l'islam qui
n'est pas une église
elle fait aussi des vétilles que julie
qui est pas église effet betty ok mais
il parle pas de dieu à aucun moment
s'est alors déclenchée
non évidemment je parle de dieu puisque
j'essaie de montrer comment à partir de
feuilles urba qu'on a on a construit du
avec l'impuissance des hommes donc un
chapitre entièrement consacré à cette
idée que dieu supposé impuissance des
hommes la capelle incapacité à accepter
d'avoir reçu à désolé mais ce qui m'a
frappé dans votre livre c'est que vous
ne croyez pas du tout enfin vous ne
parlez pas du tout de l'incarnation ce
mot n'existe pratiquement pas
alain carton sujet c'est pas mon sujet à
bercy on peut me reprocher d'avoir écrit
un livre sur la religion mais vous
auriez dû écrire sur l'incarnation c'est
pas mon problème et attendait messi
parce que dans la rue
on voit sans problème alors si vous
voulez séduire alors un instant après
quoi vous jouez dans la religion
chrétienne le fondement de la religion
chrétienne c'est qu'il ya un dieu qui
s'est fait homme son appel l'incarnation
ça fait la grandeur de l'homme et non
pas le mépris de vous fait l'histoire
des religions dans un style plutôt paf
les terres je dirais pas d'accord du
tout allez vous appelez ça un traité
alors moi je dis ça m'intéressait avant
franchement je vous jure s'arrêter c'est
beaucoup je dis voilà quelqu'un qui se
dit athée wac on se disent agnostiques
je veux bien parce qu'on dit à la
première les agnostiques font quand même
le lit de tous les gens qui croient les
agnostiques athées agnostiques vie je
sais pas si les v6 un adieu aussi en a
pas vous vous dites il y en a pas
laissez moi vous dire qu'alain et comme
vous vous avez décidé qu'il y en avait
un abb moi j'ai les gens qui en ont
témoigné qu'ils sont fait tuer pour sa
déclinaison il ya aussi des gens qui
sont morts pour des idéologies qui était
déplorable des gens sont morts pour le
nazi c'est pas une bonne idée de
considérer que parce qu'on morts pour
une bonne humeur pour une idée c'est une
bonne idée
on parle de votre île du contenu de
votre livre j'aimerais que un instant on
vous laisse un tout petit peu la parole
pour dire ce qu'il ya dans votre vie
parce que on en parle comme si tout le
monde connaissait beaucoup de monde le
connaît mais j'aimerais bien que vous
défendez votre thèse
alors je vais le laisser plan oui parce
que parce qu'effectivement jeu il n'est
pas question pour moi de parler de
l'incarnation une question de parler de
la religion sens large et âme et des
trois monothéismes dire d'expliquer
comment les trois religions
livrons un certain nombre de dossiers en
commun la haine de la raison la haine
des femmes l'un du désir du plaisir
l'aide du corps n de la ville à une de
la chair et ses héritages de montrer que
ces religions là ont ça en commun alors
bien sûr elle se distingue des unes des
autres
et j'ajoute que dans l'histoire mais
n'était pas de mon fait décrire le génie
du christianisme déjà été fait donc un
peu effectivement me dire que le
christianisme a apporté un certain
nombre de choses positives et j'y
consens je dis simplement que cette
religion d'amour de ces trois religions
d'amour ou amené beaucoup de haine
beaucoup de persécution beaucoup de
massacres et d'ailleurs jacques duquesne
le dit dans son livre dans son ouvrage
il a de très belles pages sur le rwanda
je suis très heureux qu'un chrétien
puisse écrire sur leur honda ce que j'ai
envie qu'elle n'a pu écrire parce que
moi quand j'en parle on dit que c'est un
pamphlet alors que je ne suis pas dans
la logique du pamphlet je dis simplement
des choses qui sont dures à entendre les
choses dures à entendre ne sont pas
forcément concepteur cela dit qu'on vous
le dit par exemple la haine du corps
alors je vais revenir avec l'incarnation
j'allais dire je n'ai pas fait un livre
sur la relation qu'ont pensé que c'est
un dieu qui prouve dans le christ et qui
prend un corps qui dimanche
il boit ya beaucoup de scènes de
l'évangile qui se passe à table et céda
qui je m'excuse fait ses besoins comme
vous et moi
pas du tout donc je dis dans la boue
dans le nouveau testament
il n'y a pas d'endroit où on voit le
christ déféquer on ne le voit pas manger
autre chose que du symbole inapa de
sexualité il n'y a pas de désir ça vous
n'en savez rien justement c'est bien ce
que
c'est clair aucun renseignement sur le
désir sur le plaisir sur la chaîne en
tant que tel c'est une chair qui
n'existe pas c'est un anticorps le corps
du christianisme et heures si vous
permettez c'est parce que les évangiles
et après les évangiles ont été
contaminés par la culture grecque que
vous portez aux durées culture grecque
méprise la matière méprise corps platon
et les autres voilà vous dépassez la
culture grecque tel que le christianisme
nous la présente moi je passe tout mon
temps à l'université populaire et pour
montrer qu'il n'y a pas que platon dans
le christ y est donc dans le dans la
pensée grecque
epicure par exemple du crès diogène de
landas les épicuriens les signes et les
cyrénaïque des fameux grecques auquel je
me réfère pas les vos travaux grecque
n'est pas grave parce qu en fait c'était
quand même les platonicien et les
néoplatoniciens qui dominait pas du tout
ne dominait pas le christianisme quand
il a écrit l'histoire de la philosophie
a dit qu'effectivement le platonisme
était dominant a détruit des manuscrits
incendié des bibliothèques à tuer des
philosophe hypatie philosophe
platonicienne a été tués par des
chrétiens pour détruire toute la
tradition matérialiste et donner du
jubilatoire de la philosophie grecque
pour dire il n'ya qu'une philosophie
celle qui prépare le christianisme et
c'est le platonisme rien pas vous
n'abordez pas c'est la religion et les
femmes et sur ce point vous êtes pour le
moins cher vous n'abordez pas dans votre
débat mais que vous bien évidemment vous
abordez j'aimerais que vous
en parler michel onfray je voulais bien
payés sans merci bien voilà il ya une
détestation de du corps des femmes ça
démarre avec avec la génèse des premiers
versets de la génèse font la
démonstration que dieu interdit
on goûte du fruit de l'arbre de la
connaissance et eve elle dit mais moi je
veux savoir celle qui inventa
philosophique d'une certaine manière
moi je peux me contenter de l'obéissance
et de la foi je veux savoir je vais
goûter du fruit de leurs meules à cônes
essentiels haga nation arrive par la
suite et giresse péché originel
on en fait dans la douleur on travaille
on va souffrir on va mourir on va
vieillir et c'est en fait toute la
négativité du monde possèdent des femmes
non mais le péché originel je suis les
deux ça arrive cinq siècles après
jésus-christ c'est à dire c'est loin de
là veut ça n'a pas beaucoup de rapport
nous titrons des patrons j'existe yen à
vous et vous ne défendez pas trop vous
dire je n'aime pas perdre je suis con
alors connaît pas oui moi je j'essaie de
me référer aux à l'évangile lui même
qu'est-ce qui entourait jésus il y avait
des pins de familia et marie madeleine
il est jeune la femme n'attendant
d'hérode etc
mais les machos qui entourait faut bien
se replacer à l'époque les machos qui
entourait jésus jésus j'ai de la
sympathie pour ce sympathique et de la
sympathie pour jésus simplement c'est
sympa lui qui dit des méchancetés d une
vilenie complexe sur les femmes et le
christianisme s'est pas construite sur
jésus le christianisme s'est construit
sur saint paul
si le christianisme était construit sur
jésus certaines de vos thèses la
contamination vous devez aimer le
flécher ceci bâti sur marie et marie
c'est quand même une femme à ma
connaissance et une femme c'est une
épouse et une mère c'est le contraire
d'une femme parce qu'on vous dit marie
s'est pas c'est pas la femme qu'on
vénère ans marie c'est la vierge c'est
la mer merck a pas eu de relation
sexuelle avec un homme pour faire son
fils aurait pas certain alors à d'autres
vous dites on n'en est pas certain
seiler crucifixion vous remettez en
question
j'allais dire historiquement
la crucifixion de jésus oui moi je dis
même que l'existence historique briller
ses distances historique de jésus n'est
pas avéré et que acceptons même le
principe d'une existence réelle et
physique de jésus si on l'avait condamné
lorsqu'on lui reproche
on l'aurait la fidélité on m a crucifié
ensuite lavé admettons même que le
crucifix on l'aurait pas crucifié sur
une croix comme celle ci mais c'est sur
une croix de saint-andré et ça ce serait
pas du tout passé comme ça on n'aurait
pas que tout est de la même manière et
sert d'aucune espèce de vous dit le
tombeau s'est hissée un bon jour on va
répondre
alors écoutez les juifs n'aient pas le
droit de lapider il était sous la
colonisation romaine le juste glady
c'est à dire le droit de tuer d'exécuter
et p&o romain un autre à un autre point
important dans votre la religion c'est
interdit je crois que vous développez
abondamment cet esprit nous on vous en
parle vous savez que ça d'ailleurs la
religion ils nous disent qu'il ne faut
pas faire ou ce qu'il faut faire et les
prescriptive et les sommes d'interdits
qui se trouve dans l'ancien testament
c'est considérable ce qu'on n'a pas le
droit de manger ce qu'on n'a pas le
droit de porter comme vêtement c'est un
peu le bras de fer dans un jour
particulier ce qu'il faut faire avec les
femmes comment il faut s'y prendre comme
il faut s'y prendre avec le bétail avec
c'est à dire s'il ya que de l'interdît
dans le
l'ancien testament vous avez dit mais il
n'ya pas que de l'interdît qui a quand
même il ya aussi il faut se tenir
convenablement avec sur les deux voisins
etc et dans le nouveau des salles en
jésus est une femme extraordinaire c'est
pas aimez vous les uns les autres ça il
y avait beaucoup d'autres gens qui le
disait le rabat idel d'autres rabbins
etc mais jésus disait aimez vos ennemis
mais c'est vrai vous avez tous
construits vous sur paul et vous essayez
de nous démontrer que c'est dire sa foi
l'un des membres élus saint paul qui a
fondé le critias les formateurs du
christ qui s'appelle jésus ça s'appelle
pas parole l'apf fondateur de christine
c'est constantin qui officiellement fait
passer cette petite secte de rien du
tout à une religion dominante du pouvoir
impérial c'est quand même pas rien non
mais attendez il n'existait pas dans la
moitié de la gaule à peu près avec les
chefs dans le sud et dans le nord chez
moi là il y avait quand les francs sont
arrivés et cetera il n'y avait pas de
pêcher à libé avec peu défaillants comme
le christianisme n'est pas encore
officielle à cette époque là il se
constitue sur des siècles de violence de
brutalité d'incendié bibliothèque de
destruction des dix est d'accord avec ça
et berbère il se construit pas là dessus
il se construit en partie avec ça et un
texte de droit qui équivaut je dirais
les lois de vichy à l'époque où le code
noir en plein xviie siècle le code de
théodose cote de justinien est un code
qui interdit la citoyenneté la cité même
à quiconque n'est pas chrétien c'est à
dire que légalement juridiquement on
interdit l'existence à quiconque n'est
pas chrétien ce à partir de ce moment là
effectivement qu'on construit et gars
christianisme officiel élèves ont
interdit aux païens d'avoir la
possibilité de tester vérité de
témoigner
de l'enseigné d'être des fonctionnaires
de travailler dans l'administration
très exactement mais là vous avez raison
mais vous devez vous ne prenez que les
épisodes noirs construisent le
christianisme jacques duquesne j'ai vu
poser qu'est ce que l'athée proposerait
aux croyants qu'est ce que le croyant
proposerait à lattes et aujourd'hui
après avoir écouté les arguments de l'un
et de l'autre et répond à la lumière et
vers l'ue allait répondre pour la vie
moi je suis d'accord avec le livre de
jacques duquesne d'abord parce que j'ai
il fait un truc qu'on n'a pas fait je
crois en philosophie c'était bien
beaucoup d beaucoup de textes sur la
question du mal sur les questions de
négativité du rap du rapport à dieu si
tu existes
pourquoi y at-il du mal et je trouve que
là la thèse intéressante de jacques
duquesne c'est que dieu est un parfait
et qu'il a créé l'homme imparfait dans
un monde imparfait
dernièrement c'est une très belle thèse
et je peux pas être content retiens je
dirai simplement à jacques duquesne qu'
il n'a pas besoin pour être cet homme
qu'il est c'est-à-dire humaniste de
qualité pas besoin du christianisme et
de dieu pour ça la morale suffit et la
philosophie suffisant vous vous dites
que j'ai pas besoin du christ chérie je
vais de dieu mais c'est quand même fait
qui m'a inspiré d'être ce que je suis
j'ai été nourri à ça j'ai toujours été à
la laïque elle à votre différence je
crois mais j'étais nourri par le christ
est gelée tt comme le doivent jeter le
lait de ma mère est vraiment ça
m'inspire encore ce lundi avec ce que
vous venez de dire que j'étais d'accord
avec moi ça et mes deux derniers délais
mais de livres précédents été condamné
par les évêques
je suis sûr que grâce à vous je vais
être condamné encore une fois de plus
jacques du week-end michel enfin je vous
remercie en tout cas je suis certain
qu'on a été très intéressés par le débat
et que nos téléspectateurs auront envie
de lire vos deux livres que je rappelle
jacques duquesne dieu malgré nous et
michel onfray traité d'athéologie et la
tradition dans notre échec et max et que
vous seriez là même ce manuel
merci beaucoup et puis nous on est pour
la tolérance je suis heureux qu'ils
aient déserté
[Musique]